[Music]
right here in our hemisphere there's a
very dramatic confrontation playing out
in the streets of Caracas Venezuela were
the people there are standing up to a
narco dictatorship that has denied their
basic rights failed to respect elections
also what's happening is that the
inter-american community is standing up
after about 10 years of ignoring this
problem and marshalling a response
saying the regime there is accountable
to its international commitments to
respect the separation of powers and
democratic order and to respect human
rights and they call for elections to
bring about a democratic transition in
that country the United States is
standing with the inter-american
community playing a supportive role by
bringing sanctions against individuals
at the very top of that government by
the president of Venezuela as a matter
of fact for engaging in narco
trafficking and money laundering
violating our laws finally the
Venezuelan people feel that they're not
isolated that the United States and
their neighbors are standing with them
as they call for the restoration of
democratic order in that country what
should the u.s. role be in helping
Venezuelans restore democracy in their
country please let us know in your
comments and also let us know what other
topics you want ADI scholars to cover in
60 seconds